[Music]
i'm patiently waiting for you
oh it sounds so much cooler i know
everything in spanish sounds so dope
everybody they both sounded kind of a
little italian
like a cream sauce yeah for the first
edition
that's funny okay well well what we are
going to talk about has nothing to do
with italians
but i want to figure that okay
it does have to do with a very a very
giving company which you would not
expect
amazon no or you would not expect where
this
this company is located in china
that's so funny we don't expect it
because we don't think they give
anything
i know your minds that's why i'm tapping
into your mind
so a chinese steel production company
recently made
international news because of the fact
that they
gave a discount 4 116
of its employees a coupon a car
a car a brand new car
106. that's a lot dude what brand is the
car
what kind of car ching hua what's that
indian car oh
that is sing towel beer shing tell car
car
it's so they gave 2 900
jangling ford territory jangling ford
looks like a chinese ford car
dangling for yeah and 1183
faw volkswagen magoton
it's like the international names for
their cars just so it's different damn
these look sick
oh damn that is a phone oh that is
really nice those are real chinese farms
ain't got no [ __ ] fog lights on them
oh that is so cool
4 000 new cars and then you know that
you know that thought that we all get
when taxes exactly
the taxes were all like oh that's nice
they got a huge gift but what about the
taxes what about the autopsy
for all of it they paid for it too but
but what about
are they spying on these people in their
car most likely because
they are already what about spiders did
they have seats in the inside
you got to pay for the seats yeah nope
no
steering wheel it's just the outside car
you get the gas pedal but not the brake
pedal oh [ __ ]
there's no tie on it only the brake
pedal not the glass
one seat belt one seat belt only hey
they get seat belts
no that's beautiful i think that's tight
isn't that amazing i like how we cut it
all down like
it's spying where's the catch that's
cool that they're changing their
branding though i love that that's gotta
be like 10 million dollars or some [ __ ]
what company
it okay so the company is jiangxi
west da da ju iron and steel
corporation that's just [ __ ] hard
dude
the calculator broke it didn't even let
me you have a use your phone really 4
116 new vehicles yeah around like thirty
thousand dollars-ish
well it turns out that they they are
valued at around 500 million yuan
which is 74 million dollars wow
oh everything
they also that that number is not
including
the production of license plates five
years of auto insurance and vehicle
taxes
so they actually spend a lot more than
that probably 100 million
they needed a tax deduction that's what
they needed
yeah so they're saying the reason why
the reason why they gave their employees
these brand new cars is
as a bonus for surpassing profit targets
for the fifth consecutive year
that's so dope how much profit did they
get damn i know
for them to spend 75 million dollars if
you're producing steel that's what
everybody needs everything's made out of
steel that's true
you're in the cars so they'd be selling
those steel so they got it at a discount
they got it out of steel
all right they got it they got a lot of
steel man
oh yeah we found the loophole they made
it themselves that's why it's cheap as
[ __ ] or they provided this deal to make
these i want to work for a company like
this i love how you all are haters no
that's amazing you participated
absolutely yeah she's looking in the
mirror i love how y'all are hating
everyone it's nice to feel appreciated i
know
that's a beautiful gift man seriously
that's amazing i wish someone would do
that for me i would accompany
i'm going to work for them well you took
care of you guys took everybody to japan
that one yeah that's [ __ ]
dope that's just one time no no i'm
vegas
it's not the same it feels great to give
but i want to be given two goddamn what
is the sun
that's what i was talking about okay you
give yourself a lot of stuff from your
hard work too yeah but it's not the same
we gotta start giving [ __ ] to each other
look at you that's what we say
and we don't do things the smart way so
for them they hit their profit targets
right
then they give for me and joey give her
the [ __ ] we want and then taxes come
like oh [ __ ] we'll give it all away
that means you guys are giving more yeah
that's we're not doing it more like
let's
give out bonuses and then we get hit
with taxes like oh [ __ ] we should have
saved it god damn it
they're tax deductions so we paid
dollars no because it goes away
wait i thought the other way around was
like oh we have to spend this money
because if not it's going to go to the
government
yeah that's not how they think though no
but that's not that's what they say
yeah yeah yeah it's like give or take
that's okay that's what we're supposed
to do but our stupid ass
didn't do joe that's why we end up
paying double in order to get given to
you you have to work for somebody else
though
at their company do what they say can i
work for somebody here you want to work
at barbell
yep you want to work with that that was
[ __ ] fast dude yup
yup but then but he wants presents do
you guys
hook people up you get presents all the
time from barbell not with cars
no but like clothing that's true but i
didn't get the comments made money like
a steel company be a different store
yeah sorry joe i just want shorts is
that cool
yeah but then you guys have a shipment
stuck in china so i gotta wait huh well
we're coming out with start tonight
november
i'll work while you guys have shorts and
when you stop selling shorts
i'll and he'll quit my contract you need
a continuous lineup
of the worst employee ever done that's
why i don't work for people suppose job
application is terrible it's like
i'm coming here for shorts but you got a
dummy choice i'm out like
can i call your previous employer yeah
he goes yeah he showed up for about a
season when we had shorts and then uh
you know when winner came around he kind
of just left
well he's like who's your previous
employer well let me show you guys hi
you're talking to him it's me it's
me he's a bow tie he puts on the boss of
[Laughter]
it's like the guy that works in all the
places at one town
you said you're gonna you're gonna flip
a flip an older car right maybe
that's one of my many ideas i have which
is very interesting
um i like i've been getting into like
old cars right now
because like cobit happened and i was
like oh everyone's into camping and suvs
right
so i'm like i want an suv i started
looking at classic suvs
like the bronco oh the bro the new
bronco looks really cool
i was looking into the land cruisers
like that oh
yes dude six miles a gallon baby you
should renovate old vans because
everyone wants to do those van life
things and
make it so there's like a bed and a
kitchenette and stuff that was my dream
and muriel crushed it why she said i
hate vans because that would have been
my only car
and then she gets a little upset when we
go to nice dinners and then yeah
and you pull up in a van well my cars
are old why can you afford a 2
dollar bike but you can't afford another
ban and well those
van builds are very pricey it's a
hundred thousand so we have to build it
yeah it's thirty thousand dollars if you
do it and you have somebody else build
it like there's companies that do it for
you it's way more expensive but doing it
yourself i don't know how to [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] do you feel how soft his hands
are
excuse me he's a [ __ ] oh hold on a
second this
this hand's super rough show me what a
hammer looks like see what does the
hammer look like what does a hammer do
it's clearly a shape that's cylindrical
and it's a little
it looks something like this yeah you're
wrong and then you go
thank you hammer nailed thank you nailed
it nailed it
yeah give me another two i bet you i
know i i know i tool i'm gonna test the
van life next week
are you gonna test van life yeah cuckoo
campers oh yeah cool
i thought they didn't think they were
out here no they're i'm going to
colorado
and then they're they have a one in
iceland and one in colorado they're a
rental camper they're a rental company
you rent a van you run an event like the
one with the bed and they have a bunch
of cargo vans that they retrofit for
like van life and they're like yeah take
it for as long as you want so we're
gonna go and oh that's
cool how fun shout outs so it's like a
sprinter van i don't know if it's a
sprinter van but they have a bunch of
different cargo vans
and it's like different sizes and then
that's so sick he's been watching for a
long time so when he saw me talk about
the van life stuff he was like
hey i know he was hitting you up too so
that was kind of cool
i just want to take those sick ass
instagram pictures where you're like on
a lake or a beach or something and you
have the
doors open and it's like your bed and
then you're yeah that was my dream
and your element hey well you could do
it now because you don't have to buy a
van you can rent one run it from them
yeah they love you i just want to build
one you want to go with me
you can go with it you can probably hit
them up and then they can like help you
build it you want the credit for
building one but you don't want to pay
the money
to have it built yeah you know me thank
you because she gets me dude that's
funny
i'm the same way yeah you get me i just
want to be like i bet i built that
you know exactly what i'm talking about
building your closet thing
i know i have to watch a lot of
tutorials and like that's a lot of time
man yeah it's mostly for the end reward
i'm just thinking about like i just want
to [ __ ]
get to the end so i could be like i did
that mm-hmm you know exactly you know if
you know what's up can you move on
to the next project yeah well i have the
people have to look at it and be like
whoa good job
like even all the [ __ ] uh the bike
[ __ ] i did i could get a bike shop to do
it but i wanted to do it myself yeah
yeah i mean what bike [ __ ] did you do
uh i just replaced most everything the
stem the pedals all this other stuff so
i had a candy yeah but then i definitely
could have saved about
like two weeks out of my life if i just
gave it to the bike shop to do it
actually took a month for me to move and
i really appreciate my place i
freaking fold my bed every morning like
it's clean how cute well yeah
you don't just make your bed you fold it
in threes i make my bed and then i
folded it oh i was like
i didn't understand what you're saying
i'm like what the [ __ ] what kind of life
are you living right now bro he
packs his betta puts it in a suitcase
i just pictured him with a cardboard and
he just went just my homeless cardboard
no i actually make my bed every morning
everything is
dope and then because i was involved in
every process there's more appreciation
to it oh 100
that's what my bike missing man make me
sad man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you